Wow season one was just like Mustang
stop it yeah
then season 2 was like you tried but you
didn't corn season three was like okay
we got control of things we're good and
then this season I just was like here's
the deal I'm gonna be happy and you're
gonna make me happy or you're gonna go
away don't kill anyone
jails not worth it man this was a great
year
okay yes Leeanne Locken is back for
season 4 of The Real Housewives of
Dallas which she says brings some new
challenges and new challengers not
afraid I know your anyone should be
afraid you should be afraid of me listen
I love a good challenge you know me I
get by when people are like you know
kumbaya all the time it's it's a little
much I haven't tried to be challenged I
like to be challenged I just don't like
to be you know attacked or Beaudette
challenged is different than threatened
exactly 100% 100% I know the difference
because let's face it I've threatened a
few people you threaten to freaking kill
me okay Marie what do you think is
killing and what I think is king or to
get my things
we've gone from Season one may be
threatening to kill people Rula Jett -
sitting back and saying you know what
let's not threatening to kill people
let's not kill anybody
isn't that lovely I do show growth
though don't you think yeah that's my
goal it always has been like go get out
of the efforts there
all right well cam was here yay and left
chill
I'm not sequence attorney Matthew
question is that yes our new weave is
messy Paley on Sabu random question for
you
who do you consider besides Deandra to
not be your friend in the group well see
what she said she's adorable
Oh we'll for sure the new girl yeah the
new girl and I are you know not
or late I mean there's the deal you know
new people come in and what's the first
thing if you really want to make a wave
who do you go for yeah okay so there it
is
there is a line in the trailer that is
seemingly about you she likes to eat
but she cannot take it but I can't so I
can't take it really what do you think
I've been doing for the last three years
sweetheart maybe you should turn a TV on
before you join a show there it is I
think I think I've been taking it have I
not I think you've been taking it and
taking it and taking it without Kate why
what kind of spit-take sorry oh I do
love a fight and spit I'm done for the
day in her mind I think it was come in
and take the old Alfa out and show me
how to do things the right way in the
best way and you know her way and you
know and I'm just not big on doing
things other people's way I think
sometimes when you're new you think you
got to come in and beat your chest and
you know show the old lioness that the
new lioness can do things better the
problem is the old lioness has a lot of
kills under a belt probably be real
careful
okay so this new girl Carrie you haven't
said her name yet I've noticed he's just
different girl what do viewers need to
know other than what you just shared
about her going into this season I mean
you know I think Bravo describes her
well she's originally from Guadalajara
Mexico she has a very thick accent and
she likes her to camp up so you know and
the thing is she connects with everyone
in the group except me okay so you know
again it's like when you purposely don't
connect with one person but you try so
hard to connect with everyone else it's
just to me it's like I'm come on I mean
come on
and here's the thing in the past what
have we learned about attacking Liam it
doesn't go well for anybody so seems
safe to say it didn't go well for Carrie
I'm still hopeful but you know the new
girl and I will get along okay you know
I'm always helpful I'm always hopeful
I'll let you be a big mean apology when
you get on your knees and apologize to
me is when I will accept you back as a
friend when I say the name DeAndre
Simmons yes how do you feel about that
name at this point in time look I have
no hatred for teondra sadly I wish I
still had love for her I really think
for the first time our viewers are going
to get to see the authentic relationship
that I don't even know if DeAndre
realizes that is our relationship and
how it existed and you know I think
it'll be one of the most interesting
storylines throughout the entire season
I will tell you we are our relationship
is better than any rollercoaster in any
country my bar you're not owning what
you've done and I think bad you are you
now you going into this season changed
up your look I feel a bit brighter yes
yes I do like but there was someone else
who also went from dark dark yeah some
more color and she's been dark her into
our life so when you saw Deandra walk in
with well you know we saw it on social
media for and then everybody alluded who
copied who and it was like who cares
alright so you weren't like oh she's
single white female
okay just taken us it people hmm
well she's not single she's a wife you
see is a white female sure she's just
white female do you have hope for that
friendship in the future or is that
chapter closed I'm always hopeful the
thing is I don't give up on people
I really don't
[Music]